coworld is one of the most unhinged
games ever created it is the Unholy and
quite frankly Shameless spawn of what
happens when you combine Pokémon
creature catching mechanics with open
world elements from games like breath of
the wild and Elden ring and resource
Gathering and building mechanics and
multiplayer from games like the forest
and Arc and then you sprinkle a nice
garnish of guns on top and it makes the
ultimate survival parody game ice cream
sunde and the thing is it's a
legitimately very fun game even though
it is still just in its Alpha stage some
of the Pokémon I mean pals are kind of
familiar looking though which means the
devs seem to either not know what
they're doing or they know exactly what
they're doing the Pokémon team is
apparently looking into the game to make
sure nothing was plagiarized but hey
that's besides the point what I want to
focus on in this video though are the
pals themselves see the aforementioned
absolutely unhinged devs sometimes have
a pretty messed up sense of humor and
this humor can also be seen all
throughout the game in the forms and
lore of the various Pals that roam the
world so here are the 10 most unhinged
most messed up pals in power world as of
the current version and for warning if
you are a kid or have kids around you
right now don't watch this video this
isn't Pokémon number 10 lmuk the grass
type number 004 in the palic another
original idea the lift Mook is a short
furry green squirrel thing that's
smarter than you might initially expect
their palic entry states that they are
as intelligent as a 5 to 7-year-old
human child and that there have also
been several accounts of lims learning
to use weapons and killing their masters
with them I mean I guess they may not
like being forced from their home in the
wild into a cramped little ball in order
to serve the will of their human for the
rest of their days like who knew am I
right you can even make their weapon of
choice in game which is apparently a
submachine gun and let them use it and
assist you in combat until they decide
not to that is it's like a nice game of
Russian Roulette number nine Flack The
Water type pal deck number 006 this cute
little blue ducky is a determined little
Speedster according to its entry it uses
its own body wash water to make waves
that it will body surf on when it's in a
hurry to get somewhere the only problem
with that is that it goes so fast that
it often ends its surfing escapades with
a fatal Collision as in they surf so
fast that they slam into a rock or wall
and literally die often something tells
me that catching aack is actually a good
thing you know to save its life from
itself you can even command them to body
surf into softer targets like enemies so
you know seems like a win-win to me
number eight the dark type KNX pal deck
number 021 the noox is one of those Pals
that raises eyebrows because it looks so
similar to an Eevee you know from that
other game series you may have heard of
it is different enough though since it's
light blue in color and wears a cape
which I think is pretty cool things get
weird when you read its palic entry
though it says that if you find nox hair
in your bedding you should leave it
where it lays and leave immediately
picking it up is a one-way ticket to a
NeverEnding night I don't know about you
but that kind of sounds like being made
un alive to me you might be wondering
why they would do this though well
they're also known as The duskin
Aristocrats so to me this means that
they believe themselves to be nobility
and will just choose to have your bed
and if you refuse to surrender your bed
and try to take your bed back from them
they will then you know end Your
Existence which is kind of rude next up
we have the neutral type toot too pal
deck number 027 the toot too is a little
twocan looking bird that walks along the
ground and lays eggs you know just like
any old bird but unlike any old bird the
toot too eggs are not actually B toot
toos they're grenades grenade eggs Gren
eggs and they use them in self-defense
firing Gren eggs at their enemies out of
their rear ends and it gets even better
when they're all out of Gren eggs they
themselves will become a grenade and
explode ending their own life in firy
combustion whether or not they do this
on purpose or we're just trying to
squeeze out another Gren egg is unclear
but both of those are equally tragic and
messed up number six the ground type
hungu palic number 032 this pal is a
flying long armed thing and its arms are
apparently extremely strong so strong in
fact that they can rip apart iron
apparently some people used these Pals
and their arms to execute criminals by
stringing them up in a Public Square for
everyone to watch as the hungu would rip
the skin off of their bones the
alternate version of the hungu known as
the hungu Crist ice type number 0 32b
was used to punish great centers of
towns by tearing their hair out of their
heads using their icy strong arms as a
form of humid humiliation honestly I
don't know which hongu I would prefer
for punishment number next the neutral
type Nightwing palic number 038 the
Nightwing is a huge Darkly colored
deadly bird of prey that makes for a
nice tough Mount relatively early on in
the game however just like all the other
Pals on this list they're pretty messed
up it is said that they will carry in
young newborn Pals of other species in
order to raise them in their nest as a
surrogate parent which if it's not
abduction kind of sounds nice except for
the fact that after they raise them and
fatten them up a bit the Nightwing will
then hunt the baby pal for food I mean
talk about daddy issues am I right seems
like a lot of trouble for a little snack
but you know I digress number four the
electric type doy palic number 062 the
dozy looks like a purple skinned little
dude that floats around in a cloud like
a litu from Super Mario similarly to the
Nightwing it will befriend lonely Pals
that it finds out in the wild by being
kind to them and I know what you're
thinking finally an actual nice pal but
no it gets worse the moment that the
lonely pal mistakes this kindness from
the dozy for actual companionship the
dozy will then blast them with a
thunderbolt just for fun and it Smiles
the whole time what a prick number three
the dark type marra palic number
066 also known as the messenger of death
it is said to relish The Peculiar scent
that living things give off when they're
near death so if a marra has taken a
liking to you it's safe to assume that
that is the reason and personally I'm
not sure if this is offensive or
threatening like is it a sign that I
need to shower because it's been 4 weeks
since I've touched water or is it a
message that I smell like I'm about to
die because it's about to cause me to
die either way it's kind of creeping me
out so moving on number two the grass
type lilene pal deck number 104 this pal
is a very tall plant lady looking thing
with a flowing dress and Flowers in her
hair and they're known as The Lily
Empress apparently they're pretty docil
and said to be full of love they even
watch over small Pals who have lost
their parents like a oneperson orphanage
however for Pals that it considers to be
naughty it will apparently unleash a
full power solar blast move to
discipline them the thing is that's a
really powerful move and especially on
small baby Pals a hit from a full
powerered one would definitely be a
one-way ticket to the afterlife meaning
it straight up commits baby murder the
alternate version the ly knocked number
104b is even weirder because they will
admonish any who are disrespectful with
a painful slap but according to the
palic entry some Pals will actively seek
out this punishment they're into it
although I guess this one is more so
calling out the kind of messed up
behavior of those Pals that are into
being slapped before we get to the most
messed up pal in the entire game I'd
like to talk about one other species as
an honorable mention the ground type
dumad pal deck number 043 apparently has
reflexes that are so slow when they
relaxed that if they were cut in half
from head to tail it wouldn't even
realize it should be dead until the next
morning Honestly though I kind of want
to know it's secret the ability to relax
like that sounds wonderful number one
the most unhinged pal of all by far is
the neutral type love Ander palic number
69 nice the love Ender is a giant Pink
anthropomorphic lizard that has fur
shaped like a heart on its chest and a
heart shape over
its well it's groin there's really no
other way to say that according to its
entry this pal called the pal on the
prowl apparently spends its nights
always chasing someone around seeking a
knight of love at first it only showed
interest in other Pals but in recent
years even humans have become the target
of its debauchery debauchery literally
means sensual Pleasures typically in an
immoral fashion by the way in case you
were wondering and in case the love
Ender description palic number nickname
design and even walking animation
weren't enough already when they're
defeated they also drop suspicious
juices strains juices memory wiping
medicine and cake and you might be
thinking oh that's cheeky cake means
booty in real life so maybe the love
Ender got some booty but no it's even
more explicit than that you see in pal
World cake is necessary for breeding
which proves that the pal on the prow
really has only one thing on its mind
and that's the list let me know if you
discovered anything new in this video or
if there were any messed up pals that I
forgot about and let me know in the
comments below which pal is your
favorite please consider leaving a like
on this video If you enjoyed it and
subscribe if you haven't already for
much more gaming lore including the very
high possibility that I may or may not
be working on a pal World lore video as
we speak the lore of the bosses in fact
so so you'll want to stay tuned for that
thank you so much for watching and a
huge thank you to my Bandit crew who
keep the channel alive that's all I've
got for this one so be sure to follow me
on my socials watch out for love Enders
out there and I'll see you next time
this is Bandit signing out
[Music]
peace